good day this is a slimmer guys video
involving Pyrex you've got a couple of
sizes here I noticed that on the warning
label yeah it says avoid sudden
temperature changes not for use on the
stovetop so this is slow mo guys you
know that we like to ignore all warning
labels and do exactly what it says not
to do we just treat them like an
instruction manual on how to destroy
itself yeah what will make a good slow
mo guys video ah excellent
apparently I read the Pyrex in the US is
is different in that it's slightly
crapper than European Pyrex it's a lot
crapper yeah because it's made of
something called some soda lime glass
yeah and yeah Boris silica silica which
is what's in the Europe for this video
which will hopefully be glass cracking
and splitting everywhere we need a much
higher framerate than usual so we've
bought in the big guns the 2511 shoots
way faster I'll start filming at 28,000
frames a second at 720p and uh you know
it's doing a lot of work because it's
loud as heck what's a bit hot that's an
understatement
38 degrees out here man a blue rubber
and flame proof suit it's like I'm in a
greenhouse that's what I was in June in
Texas disgusting July it's July July
yeah alright so what we're gonna do is
get this blowtorch and act like it's a
stove top like a gas stove heat up the
Pyrex get some ice-cold water and just
put a little bit in there and hopefully
I'll just explode in my hands hello dip
dip dip dip and we'll film it on this
bad boy
lads and ladies do not try this at home
you ready yeah so tell me when I'm in
frame and that is just what I'm gonna be
that's perfect there but we can we can
readjust when you're right absolutely
ready okay
I'm absolutely ready okay let me get
final folk okay go for it good very good
that's insane what framerate sits at 28
sow
28 bow that's the starting point is it
lip at last 28,000 frames a second it
just went straight round in there there
was no messing around I like how I'm
holding it and then I'm suddenly holding
nothing so my hand just goes that work
it does actually explode hmm to stop the
glass going everywhere in the garden I
decided to put it up all in down didn't
work the glass was so hot that he just
melted straight through went on to the
grass anyway look at it look all these
holes
I bet the glass didn't even notice the
top no it just landed in the grass or
thought Oh was that completely pointless
that was great we uh we do need to go
faster so I'm gonna lower the rest and
go waist down to death with it that'll
give us 120,000 FPS oh good meaty meaty
meaty
because slow the waters forward there's
nothing's happening nothing's definite
well what is happening as the pirates
as you can see I've sacrificed my lab
coat to call the camera that's good of
you
it's rather hot yeah I noticed in the
first clip that all of this shattered
pretty smoothly all the lines but the
handle turned almost into dust so what I
want to do is go as fast as we can
really sort of 170,000 an acceptable
resolution on just this bit so we can
hopefully see that happen
SuperDuper extreme Oh Bonanza fast any
more adjectives or open a hundred and
seventy one thousand and a half frames
per second fremantle that's disgusting
tell me if I'm out of frame again
push it Robin just win without you
didn't even touch it
really yeah oh my god were you framed up
yeah who needs water
that's ridiculous it's just the air
calling it down was enough that much
barked at me
welcome to the handle though did the
handle go oh oh the handle didn't even
go didn't it
no okay so now we're using the second
one that partially smashed and just
focusing on the handle and this is being
filmed at three hundred and forty three
thousand frames per second that is
insane that isn't that is absolute
madness
that's a dank film rate this is over
thirteen thousand times slower than you
can see with your own face did it go I
think it did you know it's still really
hot but look at the amount of detail the
amount of cracks there in that it's just
completely can't even see can you what's
amazing as well is the fact that it was
attached to the rest of this I just
heated up this bit and only this part
cracked yeah only this part went no hard
enough the rest of this is just like
yeah I'm not involved in this I'm cool
enough I'm cool enough I'm fine okay
how's this for a mental step that the
camera recorded for 5.1 seconds yeah and
generated 19 and a half hours of fridge
I'm gonna be sick that's disgrace almost
a day of footage that's vile do you
think we should just stick it like put
it on the second channel as a whole
video just MOV by a 90 now it would be
one just put nothing in the description
how many people you think will actually
watch it to the point of like where it
does it yeah just searching through I
bet that as a food the break would be
around 10 hours in probably it's so hard
to mentally get your head around how
that glass is moving that I think we
should do a comparison video of human
reaction time so at the exact same frame
rate I'm just going to drop a little
water in your eyeball and we'll be able
to tell how quickly you react to that
compared to the video we just shot of
the handle breaking yeah it's a great
idea I mean it's just gonna be like
looking at a picture yeah so I'm gonna
go like this I'm gonna go three two one
yeah okay don't move your hand away yeah
three two one good direct hit on my
eyeball really cool
well that was immense I'm always blown
away every time we film it the speed
that glass cracks yeah phenomenally fast
crazy we couldn't go without this camera
that's for sure
couldn't do it on the old flex what's
the science behind that D thing it's
called thermal shock which is where a
sudden temperature fluctuation in
material causes the stress so on the
glass you got the heat wants to expand
the glass and the sudden cold wants to
contract it so you've got two opposites
and the glass just sort of goes just
goes up yeah that's it about a
commitment the old glass just like I
can't handle it I'm out I'm done
hopefully you enjoyed that video that's
the fastest we've ever filmed so far I'm
sure one day will exceed it feel free to
follow us on Twitter subscribe subscribe
to our second channel we've got a lot of
behind the scenes stuff on there now
actually some good viewing I know by
some merch if you want sweaty t-shirts
sweaty t-shirts we sell ones without
sweat on them unless you're at work
unless you want down sweat one I want to
go faster it can't be done it can't be
done one day no do you ever stop to
think that yeah you you can but should
you